okay um
i'm sure you guys have seen this video
by now i haven't yes i have it this is
insane so this is a an alligator handler
and they're doing some sort of birthday
party thing where you know they're
feeding the alligator and there's kids
watching too yeah it'll bring out a
birthday party though
also you dummy no it's it's a it's a
place where they have those animals out
yeah so the kids just went to the
facility
they say the hardest bite
and so there's no video there's a video
yeah i'll show you the video right here
you see
this girl is freaking she's a boss
so it's her alligators yeah she's the
one that handles this particular
alligator
it's darth gator that's his name
kind of [ __ ] me up the size of that
thing these kids are probably like ah
[ __ ] and you could take a look at i'll
show you in a bit
take a look at this kid in particular
well look at this what's that
number two
[Applause]
so she grabs her hand
so she goes
he's done this before
oh he's rolling yeah and she rolls with
him yeah you gotta
break your arm
she's got that jiu-jitsu grip on him and
this guy's
awesome
too that one kid was down for the show
yeah he thought it was part of the show
he's watching the kid too
hey hey dude get a stick and pry that
jaw open
i mean i'm sure everyone's just like
what the hell just happened it's an
alligator dude don't [ __ ] with an
alligator he's choking her it looks like
he's doing yeah a rear naked sort of
that alligator's like i don't know what
you guys expect dude her composure she's
such a boss yeah her composure she
wrapped her legs around the [ __ ] i
like the guy who's doing nothing
i don't know what that was in the black
shirt because i know a lot of things but
holding her hand
look at her holder now yeah she's just
kind of [ __ ] yeah
[Music]
having a conversation with her he got in
the lime green shirt get your [ __ ]
soy get it
water get a crowbar and [ __ ]
open that thing draw a knife and [ __ ]
pierce this thing in the [ __ ] guilds
you know what cut its [ __ ] throat
kill it there let's go there you go and
watch out
super calm
yeah her composure was fun and now this
guy has to worry about the alligator
and then she's guiding him through what
to do the keys all right on right on
okay uh i'm here by myself
she's so calm
look at her doing her thing mm-hmm
[ __ ] amazing he's stuck in there
what's going on
no no
watch your hand
is that thing's going to buy it i don't
want to turn around i love his dad's
shoes
[Applause]
what the [ __ ] that girl's a badass what
happened to her arm they want to see the
pictures right now yeah
y'all gonna look here i am oh it's not
terrible yeah mark's i thought it was
worse than that
i think it's made to each her she's a
she's a badass that's alligator doing
alligator [ __ ] that's an alligator doing
how i get a [ __ ] yeah and i find her
attractive hopefully they didn't put
that
she's beautiful please stop doing that
yeah that's just too close that's so
stupid if it gets your face
that's that same alligator yeah and her
after no that's before this is happier
but she's still got her hand
she's got a body too she's gorgeous yeah
but i don't want her to get hurt yeah
this is what we're gonna alligators like
this [ __ ] is stupid
how did you get there because that's
what she's doing she's all why do you
you know you know the problem with this
this [ __ ] dead lifting and all this
tea what you're aggressive as [ __ ] do
you think yeah you yeah you call them
you get yourself you get a little like
it comes in you like one day